Your time is limited, so don't waste it living someone else's life.
Don't be trapped by dogma,...
...which is living with the results of other people's thinking.
Don't let the noise of others' opinions drown out your own inner voice.
You've got to find what you love.
And that is as true for your work as it is for your lovers.
Your work is gonna fill a large part of your life...
...and the only way to be truly satisfied is to do what you believe is great work.
And the only way to do great work is to love what you do.
If you haven't found it yet, keep looking.
And don't settle.
Have the courage to follow your heart and intuition.
They somehow already know what you truly want to become.